let me put this right here bro charlie
suggest that ronaldo was the best player
in the world no no he's not even the
best player what's that are you saying
ronaldo's the best player right now when
when we talk about great players salah
can't talk to ronaldo he can't right now
salah can't talk right now though oh my
god now those become an alien fam he's
different
you know couldn't have got me like a
liverpool fan from london
they're not taking
is coming to outside
let's go let's do it for the show bloody
hell
united centre-backs
are better than liverpool's three
two one
easy
i can do that we can take stuff off the
table bro
you got you got one amazing center back
what's what i'm doing in a united states
or one of being above anybody about
right
yeah we talk about an invader van zak
because that's what that's what the main
conversation here is yeah do you think
that harry maguire genuinely in your
heart when you really really dig deep is
better than joel mata really like really
really is shawn met him don't say who is
all right let me ask you a simple
question would you take uh
you just asked me a very easy question
wait hold on would you take verran
you've just asked me a very honest would
you take that answer your question
you've just asked me a very honest
question i'm going to give you a very
honest answer no
he's not right now on form he's not
better than mata wait what you're saying
so you're saying you're telling me for
ranting your team he's sitting on a
bench for dramatic really do you know
what about are you saying that i just
wanted to understand that
right
that's how we know
we can't trust anything he's saying
right now bro champions league
champions league champions leagues at
manchester united he didn't win them
champions
there you go
there's a flight he's attracted to he's
like
right now he caught the flowers like
yeah i'm going over there rob he said no
i'm gonna stick bro
i'll give you that okay i'll give you
that one raphael won them champions
league not at you not only that was he
the main man in that backline no it was
serio ramos world cup winning squad was
he the main man no one's hit he has a
better world cup if you go and watch it
you'll see
world cup that you're talking about for
that never happens at manchester united
yeah he asked us the question who's got
a better defense manchester united
but that's just the rights and he's been
rather shaky so far matthew has been our
best centre-back this season and virgil
vanzike is the best center back in the
world how can you tell me when you've
got an 80 million pounds screwed up
you've just got a head you paid 80
million pounds for the fat head listen
i've got a fatter painting for me and
pay me however much you're weak because
i'll do the same job that how do you do
but on the opposing side even if you
look at our depth i think kenneth is
better than harry maguire i think
goldman sachs maguire no he's not having
mcguire to start for you because he was
80 million pounds and you have to play
him listen you have to listen he is
being forced
to have some respect for the man united
captain because you were cheering for
him in this
was more of a captain yeah rashford is
more of a captain than [ __ ] mcgregor
no no no no i've just sat here and
allowed you to disrespect my wife let's
just i'll tell you you already know i
couldn't believe your questions
that was an easy one you hurt yourself
you killed yourself men said that veron
doesn't start i can't believe it
mohammed salah is the best player in the
world right
now three two one
we're gonna need a bigger table guys
we're gonna need a bigger table i just
want to hear what rubbish right so
basically the rubbish that you're all
about is that mohamed salah not only is
doing it this season he's not just
tearing up to the party now he has been
running the party that is what most
sales is
he's been running the party since 17 18
when he joined got us to a champions
league final in our first season then
got us to a champions league final the
season after and we won and the one that
we lost he was injured about 20 minutes
in after ramos listen my childhood's
been terrible no need titles this that
i'm here in liverpool that's such a big
win mo salah comes in wins us a premier
league trophy this season only looks
better he's reliable he scores goals he
creates goals and he tracks back
defensively right now there's no one
doing in the league that's what mohamed
salah is doing and then outside the
league let's be honest la liga that's
not quite
that's not the center all right
that's not the same second daddy's home
right now everything changes
is one of the greatest boxers of all
time
he's actually one of my favorite
fighters actually yes he came back the
other week and looked like an old man no
no no no no no no no no
see the old man so you're trying to see
that
when we talk about great players salah
can't talk to ronaldo he can't right now
the work that he has to do to reach this
stage he ain't done it yet yeah he's
enjoying a couple seasons here and there
but i'm telling you when you look at
cellar
no no no no
bro do you know it is because you
haven't seen this for a long time i've
seen ryan giggs bro i've seen all i've
seen players do this now you're having
your ascendancy and you're getting
excited the same way you go excited with
fernando torres you had your moments but
i'm telling you that daddy's home bro
you know that like sue you see what he's
doing let's talk about overall season
because the question cajun you can't
avoid the question i'm talking about
he
i might actually concede this argument
and move me up a little bit over that
way i like somebody kg i like him the
accent might be throwing you off so i'll
change it up a little bit so you might
be able no no stay in scouts bro
he's the greatest greatest
greatest
what are you laughing at bro
it's
sir alex taught me to understand
skeletons
[Applause]
ronaldo
wait are you serious ronaldo that just
left juventus as a top goal scorer yeah
here you go that's ready i finished the
top goal scorer okay listen use all
right ronaldo because you've got a six
pack the difference is salad has got an
eight pack and he's actually doing
better overall he's not interested in
physical condition don't don't kiss me
i've seen his ever seen his butt i don't
mean his back i mean his backpack
he's chesty no but come on
he
like
this
from taking off the top to show them
it's ronaldo bro bro ronaldo
is his face and his shin pads that's how
good he is from he's like i'm ronaldo
bro he looks down i'm the king rob i'm
the goat you know who he is bro look at
ronaldo striker
striker helen striker yeah sally right
winger all right we're not bro ronaldo
was a right winger when he was doing the
number seven thing in four four two days
that's the right winger bro you know
he's not right we're not
league final
is the greatest champions league final
in history
[Music]
i respect
istanbul
i respect it i respect it i'm like
michelle i respect it you should it was
good good yeah good it was good you used
better objectives better description
description no no it was good it was
good go into your vocabulary a little
bit i don't know fantastic no
no
my school was in academy bro they closed
it down i haven't got no more
what i'm saying right now is the best
i've got here
right now it was good yeah now what my
boys did against bayern munich here
is the most incredible thing because it
was over
literally they we
i i remember i remember i was in my
front room and i was singing you gotta
have faith here
jumping up and down with my sister and i
was like there's no reason to feel like
this there's no way we can come back
into this bro only gone are so sharp
because of that goal that's why he's
here because his cv he shouldn't be here
but because of that amazing moment look
what happened teddy ollie oh my goodness
i still feel it right now bro you don't
piss me off bro i oh my what are we
talking about it's that ball bro because
you know it was i get the ac milan
players they were celebrating they
celebrated early they got too excited
yeah and they went mad and then after
you lost heard that and he took it you
took it personally but what our boys did
you've never seen anything like that i
know you celebrated
i mean i i know you i know you said this
you
did you see the ball as we had yeah did
you see how i started 11 on the day go
on i started eleven was nothing on the
level of ac milan you've got stephen
jeddah chaby alonso there was very few
of them yeah yeah jeezy dude second
shout out to jelly legs but either way
he is not the man who you should be
leading in the champions league final to
take you all the way i won't even speak
for myself i will speak for the people
because i am a matter of fact
no you're not the voice of the devil i
am the voice of the voice
of this situation i'm going to give you
the scenario that we are the best team
to have won that champion no you're not
and i don't mean i'll start at 11 i mean
on circumstances and i'm based on the
circumstances were crazy do you see what
we did i'm not saying anyways but uh
yeah
what it was not bro
so amazing
no no no you need this glass right here
bro this glass stays here deep down i
know you know it's the greatest thing
i've ever witnessed in my life and do
you know what happened that same year
that's cool you know what we won we won
everything fish there you go we wonder
if it's the greatest thing it's all
about this season it's the greatest
season bro we came home with all the
trophies literally every single trophy
premier league cup bro we did it
the champions league
we've done everything and that that was
that was the oh it was the greatest it's
the greatest night of my life
i'm not happy
[Laughter]
yeah do you know why i'm going to tell
you why already because you already made
a mistake i know who your next manager
is steven gerrard why is that a mistake
[Music]
that's why he's finished that's why it's
over stephen wait are you serious why am
i saying are you not seeing what we're
getting through we're going to bring
steve
what don't compare stephen jarrett only
going to soldier why not because stephen
gerard is twice the manager that only
gonna show you because he killed it do i
tell you why stephen is better now he's
sick
steven johnson
yeah we're football fans yeah high five
40 fans till the day we die let me tell
you something i watch football and no
football for what it is steven gerrard
has got a great staff room behind him
and the way they play is much better
they've actually got a philosophy at
ranges you're four years deep but only
going to associate hasn't even got a
style of play so you can't say that only
going to slow charities one absolutely
not at manchester united where stephen
jedi won the first league for rangers
and god knows how many years he's a
better manager than steven gerrard so i
understand if you don't think steven
gerrard's going to be good as jagan
klopp but don't you dare ever in the
world of sweet nancy francis bring up
steven gerrard i'm freaking only going
to sausage in the same conversation
bro bro hearken to these words i'm i'm
speaking from the future don't do it bro
okay the old school legend yeah don't
bro as someone that's getting through it
right now
please i bet actually do you know what
do it gerard in because i know it's over
he's not going to be able to manage at
the top level that we saw what happened
with chelsea
history hear me out you're competing
you talking about scottish league the
scottish league was a league that cells
have won for years steven she had he won
the damn thing did you know he's been
there
oh no
he's gonna have more experience
but do you know what i'm gonna do wait
hold on i need to talk to the camera
liverpool fans
stephen gerald has finally come in
and you're devastated
i'm just doing a message for the future
liverpool fans steven gerrard has
finally walked in and it's the end of
the season and i know you're devastated
i just want to say
i told you
i told you bro
i'm telling you okay let's just get back
to the questions
so my closing statement why um liverpool
be finished after jurgen klopp is
they're going to make they're going to
make the cardinal mistake they're going
to go with passion they're going to go
with it's going to be romantic they're
going to go romance but we know how
romantic we know what happens with
romantic movies bro
exactly and i'm talking to you from the
future and i'm saying bro don't do it
when is either retiring 20 24. uh i'm
gonna be like nostradamus i would rather
fire consecutive traculous seasons than
see my rival
win the european cup
three two one
let me see do you know if you asked me
that question before
about the premier league
all day long
strongly agree
if you said
if i would rather not win it for five
years
i'd never see you win the premier league
i would have done it because i that's
that was the worst day of my life i
would say the thing is
i was i hate my the way you hate
liverpool i hate manchester united my
childhood was just growing up on
manchester united are winning trophies
and it was not nice to see so i love it
when you don't win trophies yeah but as
much as i love it when you stop win
trophies i love it when we win trophies
even more so if even if you did even if
i did have to concede a champions league
to use i'd still rather see us going
with an fa cup in that time of year
because even though they haven't got the
the quality of the champions league in
the prem or they don't hold the prestige
i get that but you don't want to see
your team going no no no no no
well it's
listen check this out if it was a
premier league and i was
usu in my head if uh if a manager
there's a man united manager that allows
a liverpool
ma liverpool team to win the premier
league it's a suckable offense in my
head because it shouldn't happen yeah
i've never seen him
he should have been
in that moment
in that moment like remember when um you
had roy hodgson remember yes yeah right
now
i'm going to say it but right now what
are you doing i said i was like this is
someone who's been in prison for 20
years
i don't do that
such a legend at your place he was about
to go to man city i was here
come on like i said come on
black i called out no gallagher
it was all part of the master plan